salut bienvenue sur Mediapart la COP 28
à Dubaï se termine au cœur de ce sommet
organisé sous l'égide de l'ONU sommet
climat beaucoup de questions évidemment
sur les énergies fossiles et la façon de
les remplacer l'énergie nucléaire
est-elle la solution discussion et débat
avec le très médiatique très influent
expert du climat et de l'énergie
Jean-Marc jcovissi membre du Haut
Conseil pour le climat vous êtes sur à
l'air libre l'émission d'actualité et de
débat de
mdiap
donc la COP 28 à Dubaï elle se termine
c'est la COP des paradoxes comme nous
l'avons dit sur meddiapart écrit sur
meddiapart et aussi dit dans cette
émission la sortie des énergies fossiles
le pétrole le gaz le charbon y est bien
sûr évoqué et en même temps la COP est
présidée par le patron de la plus grande
compagnie pétrolière émirati on dénombre
à Dubaï euh plus de 2450 lobbyistes des
énergies fossiles c'est du jamais vu de
dans l'histoire des cops euh à Dubaï la
France et d'autres pays ont proposé une
solution le nucléaire pour sortir des
énergies fossiles alors est-ce que c'est
la bonne réponse est-ce que c'est une
fausse piste est-ce que même c'est une
erreur magistrale avec moi aujourd'hui
Jad Lingard journaliste à Mediapart
salut tu es spécialiste des sujets sur
l'écologie évidemment mais
particulièrement du nucléaire tu
documentes sur mdiapart depuis des
années euh les dégâs de cette énergie
ventée comme renouvelable et puis un
invité qu'on remercie d'être là
Jean-Marc janovissi vous êtes fondateur
du cabinet de conseil carbone 4
condateur cofondateur voilà professeur
associé à mine Paritech fondateur et
président du shift project membre je
l'ai dit du ha conseil pour le climat
alors vous êtes connu vous êtes écouté
vous êtes suivi vous êtes parfois adulé
vous êtes parfois critiqué euh vous êtes
je pense qu'on peut le dire comme ça un
militant de la décarbonation une
décarbonation dont vous pensez qu'elle
doit passer en partie par le nucléaire
et vous êtes de longue date he militant
de la décarbonation cette décarbonation
et c'est l'argument que vous développez
dans une bande dessinée le monde sans
fin coécrite avec Christophe Blin qui a
été un très grand succès d'édition en
2022 bande dessiné dont l'argumentaire a
pu être contesté on y reviendra
peut-être dans cette émission un mot sur
la COP en général ce qu'on appelle nous
la COP des lobbyistes la COP du pétrole
qui se termine vous en vous en pensez
quoi vous y croyez vous au COP la la COP
en fait il y a une petite méprise pour
les gens qui n'ont jamais vu à peu près
ce que c'est qu'une COP en fait une COP
c'est une espèce de carmèe euh dites
réunion de copro vous-même oui alors
c'est intermédiaire entre une réunion
entre une carmesse et une réunion de
copropriété sur la partie officielle
j'ai envie de dire c'estd les délégués
des États qui viennent ça ressemble à
une réunion de copropriétaire sans
syndicque sans ord et et sans et avec un
système de vote qui est on vote tout à
l'unanimité h euh une répartition des
charges qui se fait au prorat des
surface mais le vote qui se fait avec un
appartement une voie voilà et pas
d'ordre du jour c'està-dire que en fait
on doit se mettre d'accord à unanimité
sur un programme de travaux où chacun
dit voilà ce que j'aimerais faire voilà
ça c'est la ça c'est la partie
négociation et puis en marche de la
négociation vous avez une espèce de
grande kermesse alors qui participe à
cette kermesse historiquement des ONG
par exemple dans l'enceinte d'une COP il
y a des tous les stands de toutes les
ONG qu'on veut qui qui vont de la
défense des Indiens de la défense des
genres il y a des tas de trucs rien à
voir avec le climat du reste c'estz
marrant euh c'est un endroit
d'expression aussi pour oui oui Absolum
c'est une carmesse c'est un grand grand
grand truc chacun a son stand voilà vous
avez aussi des intérêts économique qui
sont là qui participent à la Kermes donc
voilà moi je me rappelle très bien à
posnan en 2008 il y avait shell qui
avait sorti ses scénarios énergétique
alors ils avaient toute une pile de
documents sur un stand qui était pas
dans l'enceinte de la COP qui était
juste à l'extérieur mais peu
importe il y a la presse évidemment
beaucoup là dans deux que j'ai fait il y
avait des milliers de journalistes je
sais pas combien il y en avait à Dubaï
là voilà donc c'est c'est une espèce de
grande kermesse et en fait une personne
qui est présente à l'intérieur ne peut
pas comprendre ne peut pas appréhender
tout ce qui se passe à l'intérieur les
interactions là cette année il y avait
pas loin de 100000 personnes on peut pas
représenter les interactions de 100000
personnes en un article ça voilà donc il
y a des truc absolument dans tous les
sens est-ce que c'est utile à la fin
alors c'est utile parce que ça permet de
parler du sujet c'est utile parce que ça
permet de confronter là où en sont les
pays mais c'est pas là que les choses se
passent dit autrement les choses qui se
décident vraiment elles se décident au
sein des États au sein des constructions
supranationales comme l'Europe au sein
des secteurs économiques au sein des
entreprises au sein des collec activité
locale c'est là que les choses se
passent et en fait à la COP on entérine
ce qui se passe déjà c'est pas un
endroit où on va faire des avancées et
en fait paradoxalement la seule COP où
il y a eu quelque chose qui ressemble
quand même un peu à une avancée c'était
copenhag parce que cette année-là il y a
eu une espèce de Hold Up du G20 sur les
nations- Unies c'est-àdire que le
processus onusien a pas du tout été
respecté dans la nuit du jeudi au
vendredi de la 2uxè semaine il y a des
chefs d'État qui voyant que ça
n'avançait pas se sont réunis dans une
salle ils ont pris une feuille de papier
ils ont dit alors sur quoi on se met
d'accord et là ça a avancé l'accord de
Paris en 2015 mais qui n'a fait quériné
quand on relit l'accord de Paris tout ce
qui était dans l'Accord de Copenhague
est dans l'accord de Paris dit autrement
il n'y a rien de plus dans l'accord de
Paris que la la légalisation onusienne
de ce qu'il y avait dans l'accord de
copenhag et l'adhésion d'État qui était
quand même ce qui avait C sur sur le
fond c'est le c'est le c'est le c'est le
le le le jeu de kille a été chamboulé à
Copenhague et c'est ça s'il avait pas eu
Copenhague il y aurait pas eu Paris
c'est ça c'est ça qui est intéressant à
savoir et est-ce qu'on on reviendra au
nucléaire après et aux autres énergies
mais est-ce que sortir du pétrole en
sortir un peu en sortir rapidement
sortir progressivement sortir à terme
est-ce que ça peut sortir des cops
c'est-à-dire est-ce que ça sortira pas
des cops parce que le pétrole a fait le
20e siècle en fait le pétrole c'est le
20e siècle je suis habillé avec du
pétrole ça c'est du pétrole je parle
dans du pétrole je suis venu ici avec du
pétrole je suis venu à vélo mais le les
PNY du vélo c'est le pétrole j'ai roulé
sur du bitum qui était du pétrole ce que
je vais manger ce soir sera
partiellement issu de la mondialisation
parce que fertilisé avec des engrais
fait au gaz enfin le pétrole est
absolument partout dans nos vies
aujourd'hui on se rend pas compte donc
en fait sortir du pétrole je vaux pas
dire c'est retourné au 19e siècle mais
il y a quelque chose de ça je je je dis
bien ça n'est pas mais il y a il faut
bien comprendre encore une fois le
pétrole c'est le 20e siècle donc en
sorti le pétrole c'est le temps libre le
temps travailler a été divisé par de en
France entre 1900 et 2000 le pétrole
c'est l'urbanisation le pétrole c'est la
tertiarisation le P enfin tout ça c'est
les énergies fossiles c'est les
retraites c'est les études longues tout
la productivité du travail qui a été
permise par les machines a permis toutes
ces avancées sociales donc dire je je
vais garder tout ça je vais garder les
retraites bien payées les études longues
la tertiarisation et cetera et je vais
me débarrasser de ce qu' a physiquement
historiquement permis ça c'est un défi
absolument titanesque donc c'est pas
dans les copquel nous sommes là
absolument donc c'est pas dans les cops
que ça va se décider dans les cops ça va
éventuellement s'entériner et encore une
fois comme je le dis la COP c'est la
cour de récré c'est la kermè dans
laquelle les gens se confrontent se
comparent voit où en sont les copains et
cetera et c'est un endroit où il y a
beaucoup de journalistes pour en parler
et qu'on aurait dû les faire l'été dans
l'hémisphère Nord puisque comme les gros
émetteurs sont dans l'hémisphère nord et
que l'hiver il fait froid moi je suis
sûr que si on avait mis ça en plein
cannard l'été ça aurait avancé un peu
plus vite voilà la COP qui a eu pour en
venir au au fond du sujet notre émission
qui est le nucléaire justement sur cette
possibilité de de sortir du pétrole et
et comment il y a eu une annonce
surprise donc à cette COP ENF en tout
cas qui avait été un peu annoncé avant
mais parmi pas mal d'annonces il y a eu
une annonce multiplié par 3 les les
capacités nucléaires dans le monde d'ici
2005 50 22 pays dont les États-Unis qui
émetteur massif évidemment d'énergie
d'énergie fossil la France les Émirats
arabes unis donc les organisateurs de la
COP et puis plein d'autres pays
notamment européens à triblé les à
triplé les capacités de l'énergie
nucléaire dans le monde d'ici à 2050 par
rapport à à 2020 c'est-à-dire qu'on est
aujourd'hui à 9 % à peu près de la
production mondiale d'électricité par
par le nucléaire en 2022 et ce serait
donc de tripler cette capacitél euh
l'objectif c'est bien sûr de réduire les
énergies faussi l'annonce elle a été
faite par John Kerry puis il y a aussi
le Japon la Corée du Sud le Royaume-Uni
voilà et Emmanuel Macron évidemment l'a
défendu euh tripler les capacités
nucléaires en 2050 d'ici 2050 en quoi ça
peut aider à lutter contre le la crise
climatique alors ça dépend si on fait ça
en plus du reste ou à la place du reste
ouais historiquement en fait ni le
nucléaire ni les nouvelles énergies
renouvlabl éolien et solaire nont
remplacé les fossiles c'est les deux se
sont rajoutés à des consommations
fossiles croissantes
il y a eu des pays où localement ça a
remplacé par exemple en France la
génération électrique avant les chocs
pétroliers était faite pour partie avec
du pétrole et le programme nucléaire a
remplacé une partie de cette génération
électrique donc en France il y a
vraiment eu une substitution mais si je
regarde macroscopiquement à l'échelle
mondiale pas le cas c'est pas le cas
c'est-à-dire que le nucléaire s'est
développé toutes les énergies sont
développées les unes sur les autres en
fait c'est ça qui est paradoxal
l'hydroélectricité c'est aussi développé
en plus du gaz du pétrole et du charbon
qui augmentait euh enfin tout c'est ce
qui est un peu perturbant et alors donc
la question maintenant c'est si on dit
qu'on va tripler l'énergie nucléaire
est-ce que en tant que tel c'est une
garantie qu'on va faire moin fossile la
réponse est non donc en fait la vraie
déclaration aurait dû être on va tripler
et virgule on s'engage derrière à virer
tant de charbon tant de gaz parce que
pétrole il y en a plus dans la
production électrique euh voilà ça ça
aurait été un argument j'ai envie de
dire inattaquable climatiquement le
simple fait de dire on va tripler bah on
peut espérer que ça va remplacer pour
partie du charbon et du gaz mais on ne
peut que les espéré c'est voilà après si
on regarde d'un peu plus près euh
vraisemblablement que sur le gaz la
production pour des raisons géologiques
devrait passer par un maximum avant
2050 pour le moment les dates qui
circulent dans les milieux que je
fréquente un peu c'est 2030 plus ou
moins 10 ans on va dire euh ce qui veut
dire
que mais c'est pas mais mais c'est pas
par volonté climatique c'est juste parce
que bah il faut des dizaines de millions
d'années pour faire du gaz donc une fois
qu'il y en a plus dans le sous-sol ben
il y en a plus dans le sous-sol euh mais
mais c'est c'est mais c'est voilà donc
pour pour que l'engagement est vraiment
force j'ai envie de dire climatique il
aurait fallu le compléter après on
remarque que ça ne fait également
qu'antériner des orientations qui
existent déjà la France a déjà pris la
décision d'augmenter ses
capacités vous interrer les Pays-Bas qui
font partie des signataires ont déjà
pris la décision la Grande-Bretagne a
déjà pris la décision la Chine a déjà
pris la décision et les Émirats Arab
Unis ont pris déjà pris la décision
aussi puisqu'ils ont déjà une centrale
nucléaire donc en fait alors bon il y a
quelques pays qui n'ont pas qui n'ont
pas de réacteurs sur leur sol qui font
également partie des des signataires
mais globalement l'essentiel des
signataires enfin ou des des gens qui
ont pris cet engagement comme comme pour
le climat il ils entérinent quelque part
quelque chose qui existe déjà jade alors
vous faites partie des personnes qui
considèrent que le nucléaire fait partie
de la solution pour réduire les gaz à
effet de serre suffisamment pour limiter
le changement climatique le
réchauffement euh si on écoute ce que
vous faites les scientifiques du climat
euh il nous donne comme limite
temporelle 2025 en disant idéalement il
faudrait que les émissions de gaz à
effet de ser connaissent un pic
d'émission en 2025 donc ça veut dire
commence à baisser à partir de 2026ant
si donc c'est-à-d maintenant si on veut
que limiter la hausse des températures à
1,5° qui est un des objectifs qui
figurait dans l'accord de Paris de 2015
donc on a un temps d'action qui est
extrêmement limité c'est-à-dire qu'il
faut agir tout suite urgemment or euh
développer de nouvelles capacités
nucléaires ça prend du temps et si on
reprend l'exemple de la France que que
que vous donniez l'annonce du de la
relance de ce programme nucléaire
nouveaux ZPR au plutôt du plutôt c'est
pour dans 10 ans ces nouveaux réacteurs
euh euh si on compare ces deux
temporalités agir tout de suite
disponible dans 10 ans en fait à quoi ça
sert de mettre de l'argent et de
développer des des capacités de
production d'électricité qui seront
prêtes après la bataille alors beaucoup
de questions dans la question on va
déplier il a beaucoup de questions la
question d'abord le le mon soutien
historique à l'énergie nucléaire il il
doit se mettre avec une virgule c'est
virgule si on veut pas que ce qu'on a
coutume d'appeler le pouvoir d'achat
s'effondre de trop moi j'ai aucun
problème avec le fait de ne faire que de
l'éolien que du solaire plus de fossile
plus de nucléaire mais il faut bien
comprendre que la contrepartie c'est un
pouvoir d'achat qui qui diminuera
beaucoup plus vite parce que ça limitera
beaucoup plus fortement la capacité de
la quantité de machine qu'on pourra
mettre au travail he et aujourd'hui
voilà donc c'est c'est c'est y a il y a
quelque part une préoccupation sociale
dans ce que je raconte même si
aujourd'hui ça coûte de moins en moins
cher de produire de l'électricité avec
question plus déjà ESS répondre
question on viendra question d'argent
après
ou donc la temporalité tout de suite et
al ensuite il faut bien voir que avec le
nucléaire ce qui est compliqué c'est de
faire une centrale par contre faire
fonctionner un réseau avec du nucléaire
c'est très simple avec des éoliennes et
du solaire c'est l'exacte inverse c'est
faire un panneau ou faire une éolienne
c'est simple faire un réseau complet
avec que ça c'est très compliqué du
reste personne n'y arrive pour le moment
pu ré d'électricité oui oui puisque
l'Allemagne aujourd'hui par exemple
juste pour donner un exemple l'Allemagne
avait 100 GW un réacteur nucléaire sa
puissance c'est à peu près 1 GW d'accord
pour l'Allemagne avait 100 GW depu
puissance pilotable électrique en 2002
c'est-à-dire si j'ajoute ce qu'il y
avait en charbon en gaz en nucléaire en
hydroélectricité c'est des centrales où
je tourne le bouton et j'en ai plus en
gros j'ai pas besoin qu'il a du soleil
j'ai pas besoin qu'il y a du vent il y
avait 100 GW en 2022 il y avait toujours
100 GW de puissance pilotable auquel ils
ont rajouté à peu près 150 GW d'éolien
et de solaire et ils ont été obligés de
garder la puissance pilotable tout
simplement parce que ils ont besoin d'un
backup quand typiquement en ce moment si
vous avez regardé par exemple ce qui se
passe en Allemagne là depuis quelques
jours euh c'est l'hiver il y a pas
beaucoup de soleil et on est en en
conditions anticyclonique c'est pour ça
qu'il fait froid il y a pas beaucoup de
vent euh et donc le le le facteur
d'émission de l'électricité allemande
ces derniers jours était quasiment aussi
élevé que celui de la Pologne tout
simplement parce que à ce moment-là et
on on sait pas stocker des grandes
quantités d'électricité en
intersaisonnier c'est-à-dire on sait le
faire dans la journée il y a pas de
problème avec des batteries j'ai le
soleil de la journée euh je je j'allume
mon frigo la nuit ça ça pose pas de
problème par contre j'ai plein de soleil
en juillet et je veux consommer cette
électricité en novembre ça c'est très
compliqué aujourd'hui personne ne sait
faire ça à large échelle donc le donc ce
qui est compliqué avec les renouvelables
c'est de faire fonctionner un système
complet grâce à ça et la question la
bonne question c'est si je veux un
système complet est-ce que j'irai plus
rapidement avec du nucléaire ou est-ce
que j'irai plus rapidement avec des
renouvelable mais je parle bien d'un
système complet ouais c'est ça la
difficulté alors après évidemment on
peut avoir des nuances de gris par
exemple tant qu'on garde les centrales à
gaz et et à charbon européenne rajouter
des éoliennes et des panneaux solaires
ça permet de moins s'en servir et donc
ça fait baisser les émissions donc ça
c'est toujours bon à prendre mais ça ne
permet pas de viser un système
totalement débarrassé du gaz et du
charbon parce que pour ça on a besoin de
supprimer totalement les capacités
pilotables que pour le moment on a en
backup et de les remplacer par autre
chose et encore une fois je dis pour le
moment il y a des scénarios qui disent
on peut peut-être y arriver il y a pas
de démonstration par les faits et en
fait les mêmes qui font les scénarios le
lundi vous disent le mardi Artung il y a
quatre conditions à remplir pour que ça
fonctionne et on n pas du tout sûr d'y
arriver ok mais ça répond pas ok donc
donc la question du délaiagir
maintenant central prê dans 10 oui mais
parce que ce que je suis en train de
répondre c'est que ce même argument se
retrouve pour la production décarboné à
base de solaire et d'éolien c'est le
même argument à terme c'est-à-dire que
si ça met 10 ans de construire la
première centrale puis après qu'on sait
les construire une tous les 4 ans parce
que vraiment on a on a vraiment la
trouille et qu'on se dépêche bah il faut
regarder le plan complet parce que
construire un réacteur on s'en fout a
aucun intérêt de construire un
réacteurou d' il 14 on en construit 50
ou ou on s'amuse avec un mais je veux
dire bon euh alors si si on regarde le
système complet d'abord il y a un
premier truc qu'on peut faire c'est de
prolonger les réacteurs existants donc
ça ça donne du temps quoi qu'on fasse
derrière qu'on fasse des éoliennes qu'on
fasse des réacteurs et cetera ça de
toute façon ça donne du temps et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est
techniquement faisable alors ça sera pas
faisable statistiquement sur les 50
réacteurs qu'il y a il y en a bien un ou
deux qu'on va devoir arrêter avant 60
ans ou trois ou quatre j'en sais rien
mais il y en a un certain nombre
probablement la grosse majorité qu'on va
être capable de faire fonctionner à 60
ans et même un certain nombre qu'on
pourra faire fonctionner encore plus
loin parce qu'il faut savoir qu'un
réacteur le mode de fonctionnement c'est
tous les 10 ans la SN passe chez vous et
vous dit je regarde je et C à quoi ça
ressemble votre truc ok je vous signe ou
je vous signe pas pour 10 ans de plus ou
je signe ce qui en général ce qu'ils
font à condition que vous me changeiez
ceci ceci ceci ceci ceci et cela voilà
c'est en général comme ça que ça marche
et les a déjà ré oui on les a déjà mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que on est du
coup on peut les garder et il y a y a 10
ans on nenvisageait pas de les garder
aussi longtemps voilà c'est juste ça le
le le mon propos et pour ce qu'on va
faire derrière en fait la le vrai sujet
c'est pasant ce qui va se passer dans
les 10 ans qui viennent c'est qu'est-ce
qui va se passer entre 2050 et 2100
C'est ça la vraie question parce que si
on veut un système durable on l'arrête
pas en 2050 on va pas vous dire moi j'ai
un plan pour en 2050 2050 vous ses
encore vivant he moi c'est pas sûr mais
vous oui euh puis à 2051 je vous dis pas
ce qu'on fait je vous dis pas si on sera
capable bon évidemment que on doit on
doit regarder plus loin donc euh la ça
permet de de voir plus loin ce ça mais
tout parce que pour l'éolien et le
solaire c'est pareil euh aujourd'hui
pour faire un système éolien et solaire
un réseau électrique avec de l'éolien du
solaire vous avez besoin de fer vous
avez besoin de cuivre vous avez besoin
d'or vous avez besoin d'argent vous avez
besoin d'éint et cetera rien de tout ça
ne se trouve en France aujourd'hui donc
réfléchir à 50 ans ça ça ça demande de
postuler sur qu'est-ce qui restera de la
mondialisation par exemple à ce
moment-là est-ce qu'on aura toujours la
facilité à importer en grande quantité
bon et aujourd'hui ces exercices sont
pas faits d'accord c'est c'est c'est
c'est juste ça que je voudrais dire donc
on a une fausse
impression de de de de de scénario
facile d'un côté et risquer de l'autre
alors que moi ce que je dis simplement
c'est toutes les prises toutes les paril
qu'on va pouvoir faire pour l'avenir
comporte des risques tous absolument
tous et ce qui est difficile parce que
c'est compliqué dans un débat public de
faire de l'arbitrage de risque les gens
sont pas habitués à ça c'est il faut
bien expliquer c'est long c'est
technique c'est voilà mais en fait
malheureusement on arrive à une époque
où tout ce qu'on va pouvoir faire c'est
de l'arbitrage de risque mais est-ce
qu'il y a pas un risque avec euh ce que
bah pour le coup un risque un risque
mais un risque peut-être voilà politique
politique ou social Jean-Marc
jeancovissi avec avec ce que vous
décrivez c'est-à-dire en gros on garde
les réacteurs nucléaires qui peuvent
être prolongés peut-être jusqu'à 60 ans
et euh on on laisse arriver ces nouveaux
réacteurs tout en ayant ses
renouvelables et puis on voit à quel
moment est-ce que on arrive à jusqu'à
quand on arrive à piloter tout cela de
façon à ce que ça puisse tenir la
production d'électricité nécessaire ok
mais est-ce qu'il y a pas un risque en
gardant ce en gardant ce système en fait
en gros de garder à peu près ce qui est
déjà en place alors qu'en fait si on
écoute le GC mais même aussi l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie les experts
toutes les intelligences qui
réfléchissent aujourd'hui aux enjeux de
la transition énergétique et de la crise
climatique et qui disent il faut quand
même changer énormément de choses et
même vous-même d'Illes vous parlez
parfois de révolution c'est une
révolution qu'il faut faire et cetera
est-ce qu'il y a pas un risque d'envoyer
un message
contreintuitif contradictoire il faut
tout changer mais en fait bah c'est bon
on peut garder ce qu'on a déjà et est-ce
que là on n pas un message qui est un
message trompeur en fait pour une
société lu laisser penser qu'on peut
continuer comme avant alors ça on l'a
dans tous les domaines faut des
bâtiments moins per plus performant mais
on va pas tous les casser les
reconstruire donc on va quand même
garder pour une large part ce qu'on a
déjà juste on va les améliorer faut
circuler à vélo mais on va quand même
pas changer les routes on va garder les
routes mais tant qu'on garde les routes
on pourrait tenter de circuler en
voiture enfin donc en fait ce problème
là on l'a avec toutes les
infrastructures qu'on a bâti jusqu'à
maintenant et dans lesquelles on va
avoir besoin de faire du tri
c'est-à-dire certaines les peut-être les
abandonner d'autres profondément les
modifier d'autres les garder à peu près
en l'état mais pas s'en servir de la
même manière et c'est clair que on a
cette question à se pososer dans
énormément de énormément de domaines
hein et est-ce que c'était pas
finalement la force aussi de la décision
allemande qui a été si décricriée en
France de décision de sortie du
nucléaire en 2011 l'energ vende est-ce
que ça a pas été la grande force de
cette décision que de marquer une
rupture historique sociale énergétique
et de dire et de dire à une société en
fait on avait une source de production
d'énergie on la laisse tomber on passe à
une autre époque est-ce que c'est pas ça
qui manque aujourd'hui en
francetionz les chiffres l'énergie 22
n'a rien changé à la trajectoire de
consommation d'énergie en Allemagne
strictement rien ça n'a strictement rien
changé je répond j'ai regardé les
chiffres ça n'a rien changé à la
trajectoire de consommation électrique
absolument rien les Allemands continue à
avoir d'énormes bagnoles et à être
contre les limitations de vitesse sur
les autoroutes il continue à avoir de
l'industrie lourde quand ils font la
promotion autant qu'ils peuvent enfin je
veux dire ça n'a strictement rien changé
à la à la mentalité allemande absolument
rien la seule chose que ça a changé
c'est que ils ont émis plus que ce
qu'ils auraient pu émettre en
abandonnant le charbon et en gardant le
nucléaire donc je continue je je j'ai
dit que cette décision était une erreur
je persiste signes les Allemands c'est
une erreur et je finis et en plus il
nous empoisonne parce que les centrales
à charbon ça fait des particules fines
et les articulle fin des centrales à
charbon contribue à tuer quelques
milliers de personnes par an en Europe
donc la décision allemande n'a aucune
vertu ils ont quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de d'énergies renouvelaable qui
se sont dévelppé puett ils auraient pu
les mettre en plus du nucléaire où est
le problème ils auraient pu sortir du
charbon et développer leurs zici laadem
RTE et puis beaucoup d'experts dont Jad
parl dans le monde disent y compris des
gens qui ont lu votre BD et qui là il
répondent d'une certaine façon disent on
peut faire 100 % de r à condition donc
contraire de vous d'énergie renouvelable
à condition d'agir sur la demande
réduire la
conso réduire les pointe sur l'offre
développer le stockage de l'électricité
s'adapter à la particularité des
territoires à ces irrégularités dont
vous parliez pour le vent et cetera ou
le ou le soleil donc on vous dit c'est
possible la réponse qui vous est qui
vous est faite souvent c'est de dire non
c'est possible alors c'est les gens qui
disent c'est possible confondent un
scénario et une démonstration un
scénario c'est une histoire qui est
aussi vraisemblable que les hypothèses
que vous avez prises en entrée mais
c'est pas parce que vous faites un
scénario moi je peux vous faire un
scénario dans lequel je rajonis de 20
ans ça ne pose aucun problème vous
trouvez que c'est aussi réalise que ça
JeanMarc honnêtement alors ce que je
vais vous dire quelles sont les
conditions qui ne sont pas bouclées dans
les scénarios qu'on regarde d'abord les
scénarios qu'on regarde ne boucent pas
sur la matière c'est-à-dire qu'il ne
disent pas l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie la même qui disait je vais
faire frou les
moustaches quasiment totalement des ENR
et cetera vous disent ah ben non on
n'est pas sûr d'avoir assez de nickel de
cuire de lithium pour suivre les
scénarios dans le dernier World Energy
Outlook il y a un très beau graphique
qui a été sorti dans lequel ils vous
disent voilà la demande en nckel en
cuivre et en lithium qu'on devrait avoir
en 2030 enfin la quantité qu'il faudrait
fournir pour suivre le scénario nz2 donc
net Z0 et puis voilà là où on en sera en
mettant bout à bout les mines
actuellement en fonctionnement et celles
qui sont en développement et partout
c'est en dessous de 15 à 20 % et là on
parle que de
2030 donc l'Agence internationale
d'énergie vous dit et il faut savoir que
dans le scénario nz2 ils ont une
quantité de carb de CO2 capturé et
séquestré la capture et séquestration
qui est juste hallucinante c'est-à-dire
que ils envisagent en 2050
8 à 10 milliards de tonnes de CO2
capturé et séquestré par an il faut
savoir que l'industrie pétrolière
aujourd'hui elle extrait 4 milliards de
tonnes de pétrole par an donc il
faudrait doubler plus que doubler
l'infrastructure du secteur Oil and Gas
plus que la doublée alors que c'est un
secteur qui a 150 ans hein il faudrait
plus que la doublé en 25 ans pour
remettre sous terre un produit qui n'a
aucune valeur commerciale enfin ce truc
est totalement délirant voilà un exemple
de truc totalement délirant oui paste et
Adem qui font leur scénario juste pour
dire sur 100 % renouvelable eux reposent
pas sur une telle quantité deou qu'ils
ont commencé eux même à à allumer les
warnings c'est-à-dire qu'après vous
avoir dit voilà éventuellement ce que ça
voudrait dire ils ont sorti une
variante dans laqu il faut savoir que
dans le dans RTE et dans l'ADEM vous
avez un comment dire un truc qui est
pour moi totalement vraisemblable c'est
que vous avez l'énergie disponible qui
baisse considérablement et le PIB qui
augmente significativement or il se
trouve que dans ma vision du monde à moi
c'est de trucs qui sont incompatibles
vous ne croyez pas au découplage comme
on dit entre pb alors mondialement on
l'observe pas moi depuis que je regarde
ça au niveau mondial on a une
corrélation quasi linéaire entre PIB et
énergie parce que c'est parce que c'est
les machines qui bossent parce que ça ça
a été fait par une machine ça part une
machine ça part une machine ça et cetera
tout ça a été fait par des machines donc
donc non j'y crois pas et en fait il
faut voir que ces scénarios ils en pile
et donc il postule en gros en hypothèse
exogène que on va avoir de plus en plus
de moyens avec de moins en moins
d'énergie sur à quoi je ne crois pas et
il termine en disant bah voyez puisquon
a de plus en plus de moyens on a
notamment les moyens de faire ça ok mais
comme je considère que l'hypothèse de
départ est pas vraisemblable je ne
souscris pas à la à la au résultat donc
pas 100 % d'énergie renouvelable vous
êtes sur ce sur ce
discours et et je vais quand même
insister sur un point j'ai toujours dit
que le nucléaire ça ferait % du chemin
j'ai jamais dit autre chose hein
d'accord d'accord le le 95 % du chemin
ça va être des efforts absolument
massifs de sobriété et ça va être
repenser l'articulation ville campagne
avoir une structure de métier totalement
différente avoir une consommation
matérielle qui va baisser avoir des
enfin c'est c'est ça 95 % du
chantier pour pourquoi al 5 % pourquoi s
accrocher à ça si ça ne fait que 5 % du
chemin parce que si vous l'avez pas
l'effort sur le reste il est doublé ou
triplé vous dites c'est un parachute
ventrale c'est ça oui l'effor sur le
reste il est doublé ou triplé
c'est-à-dire que c'est ce qui permet
éventuellement je vais prendre un autre
un autre parallèle qui vaut ce qu'il
vaut imaginons que vous soyez poursuivi
par la mafia et tout ce que vous avez à
votre disposition c'est une voiture où
il y a une des quatre roues où le le
frein est en rade et les feux stops qui
marchent plus montez dedans ou pas moi
je monte dedans voilà donc c'est c'est
il faut bien comprendre que ce qui le
rouleau compresseur qui est en train de
nous arriver dessus dû au changement
climatique et à la à la à la déplession
des ressources d'une manière générale et
accessoirement à l'effondrement de la
biodiversité ça ça c'est c'est c'est le
le le danger majeur auquel il faut
auquel il faut chercher à échapper en
empilant toutes les marges de manœuvre
qu'on a à notre disposition voilà et moi
je pense que faire la fine bouche sur
une qui qui dans dans un contexte ça
revient à dire on a le temps le monde
confortable dans lequel on vit en fait
il va encore être là pendant très
longtemps je moi je pense que c'est
c'est un débat alors Jean-Marc jokovici
le nucléaire il amène avec lui un
certain nombre de de de questions le
nouveau nucléaire les nouveaux réacteurs
comme les anciens la France veut
construire P lit au buget à Graveline de
nouveaux de nouveaux pr aussi des ce
qu'on appelle des SMR des Small modular
reactors euh qui euh qui a qui vont être
mis en place aussi le premier problème
évidemment celui qui parle aussi
beaucoup à l'opinion publique et depuis
longtemps et qui fait qu'il y a beaucoup
de mobilisation depuis des décennies
contre le nucléaire c'est la question du
futur du futur très lointain des déchets
euh et évidemment plus on fait tour des
centrales plus on va gérer des déchets
euh est-ce que vous pensez au déchets
d'une certaine façon ce scénario du
nucléaire euh qu'est-ce qu'on fait de
ces déchetsl alors des déchets il se
trouve que malheureusement on en fait
partout et tout le temps chaque Français
génère en moyenne au travers de ses
achats donc les achats de tasses mat et
C qui ont été fabriqués par l'industrie
à peu près une centaine de kilos de
déchets industriels dangereux tous les
ans d'accord donc tous les ans un
Français ordinaire hein parce que on
achète des canapés des tables des
chaises des couteaux des magies mix et
qu'est-ce que je sais on génère une
centaine de de de kilos de c'est pas
est-ce que c'est exactement le même type
de déchet alors parfois certains sont
aussi dangereux presque que des déchets
nucléaires alors en l'occurrence c'est
pas des déchets c'est phytosanitaires
mais je viendrai juste après enfin je
peux vous le dire tout de suite de reste
les phytosanitaires sont quasiment aussi
dangereux que les déchets nucléaires
c'est si si les pesticides ouais les
pesticides ou oui c'est-à-dire que a il
y a des pesticides la même quantité en
milligram de déchets nucléaires ou de
phytosanitaire vous tue d'accord
pesticide on en on en met des dizaines
de milliers de tonnes dans la nature
chaque année mais justement on essaie de
les retirer aujourd'hui on essaie pas
d'en rajouter ok mais c'est juste pour
dire euh les déchets nucléaires on en
fait quelques centaines de tonnes par an
les les les très emmerdants euh et du
reste aujourd'hui on les stock en
surface qui est pas satisfaisant va
beaucoup mieux les mettre dans un trou
où il nous enququeront plus le stockage
géologique est quelque chose qui moi me
semble pas dangereux du tout il faut
bien voir que par exemple le pétrole
c'est capable le pétrole qui est un truc
qui est liquide et sous pression donc
c'est quand même ça diffuse quand même
plus facilement man un truc qui est
solide hein c'est capable de rester
pendant des millions d'années des
dizaines de millions d'années dans une
roche dans lequel c'est emprisonné donc
le stockage géologique si on va chercher
au bon endroit c'est quand même un truc
qui ça on aura d'autres problèmes euh la
deuxième chose qu'il faut savoir c'est
que les déchets nucléaires les plus
dangereux en fait ils sont pas dangereux
au même niveau pendant 100000 ans euh au
bout oui la radioactivité décroit donc
les déchets nucléaires ont cette
particularité à la différence des
déchets chimiques où la toxicité ne
décroit pas au cours du temps que le
dangerosité décroit au cours du temps
donc en fait ENF il y a aussi des
produits qui durent par exemple le
sésium 135 je crois que c'est 2 millions
d'années quand même pour perdre la
moitié de sa réactivité donc ça nous
emmène sur un scénario assez lo alors
plus alors plus le plus la la demi-vie
du produit est longue et moins il est
actif moins il est dangereux moins il
rayonne en gros c'est simple s'il
rayonne beaucoup c'est que ça va pas
durer gérer quoi c'est ça oui c'est ça
enfin en tout cas ça se gère plus
facilement je vais le dire autrement les
problèmes environnementaux moi je les
mets dans deux catégories il y a ceux
qu'on va être capable de léguer à nos
enfants dans des conditions où eux-mêmes
pourront les gérer et il y a ceux qu'on
leur qu'on leur met qu'on leur l dans
des conditions où ils ne sont pas
capables de les gérer le changement
climatique je le mets dans la deuxème
catégorie d'accord aujourd'hui on est en
train de leur léguer un problème qu'ils
ne vont pas être capable de gérer les
déchets nucléaires même dans un monde
très perturbé c'est un problème qu'ils
vont être capable de gérer voilà c'est
c'est c'est c'est la grosse c'est la
grosse différencead
euh voilà mais c'est et les déchets donc
je disais un déchets industriel
dangereux 100 kg par personne et par an
les déchets nucléaires de de haute
activité donc ce qui so c'est
l'équivalent d'une petite pièce de
monnaie voilà par personne et par an
donc on est sur des ordres de grandeur
qui sont quand même beaucoup plus petits
donc c'est des Franches saloperies mais
qu on accepte un risque des petite
quantité on n pas besoin de 1 milliard
de décharge pour gérer ça on a besoin
d'une décharge bien organisée mais s'il
y a un problème sur cette petite
quantité c'est extrêmement problématique
non parce que une fois que cette petite
quantité est à 400 m sous terre c'est
pas problématique du tout c'est beaucoup
moins problématique que les particules
fines des centrales à charbon ok mais si
on regarde cet exemple des déchets donc
le trou comme vous disiez c'est
s'appelle CGO c'est un projet qui est en
cours de préparation à Bur euh dans
l'Est de la France euh quand même le le
plan aujourd'hui c'est que pendant 100
ans à peu près on est euh un les les
déchets qui sont aujourd'hui stockés à
la Hague dans le côantin donc en
Normandie euh pendant 100 ans donc ces
déchets au fur et à mesure qui se
refroidissent soit conduit en train
spécialisés protégés jusqu'à CGO donc il
y a 100 temps d'exploitation avant de
tout refermer et de et d'espérer que ça
ne fuite pas mais vous trouvez pas que
ça ces transports de déchets pendant
aussi longtemps représent un risque
risque d'accident risque d'attaque on
est quand même en situation d'attaque
terroriste est-ce qu'il y a pas une
vulnérabilité là quand même
particulièrement sensible comme pour
comme pour tout euh mais justement
est-ce que c'est pas plus que
d'autresors non c'est pas tu un accident
en pardon je vous laisse répondre mais
un accident de train transportant du des
des des colis nucléaires irradié
potentiellement ement c'est pr un
accident est toujours possible pe avoir
des conséquences de pollution qui
peuvent être gravissim non c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose qui est très
gênant encore une fois quand on compare
les risques en fait il faut comparer des
faits quand on regarde la hiérarchie des
risques qu'on court aujourd'hui le
risque le plus important que courent les
Français je me demande si c'est pas
monté et descendre les escaliers qui
doit faire quelques milliers de morts
par an si enfin voilà donc on on on fum
c'est quoi le rapport enfin pardon mais
c'est quoi le rapport entre enfin
pardon quel est le rapport ent tomber
dans l'escalier et être exposé à un
risque de on est pas exposé justement
les déchets les déchets déchets les
déchets sont dans des conteneurs qui
sont résistants au choc bon si le train
se renverse le train se renverse et des
conteneurs résistants au choc se
retrouent dans le wagon qui a renversé
point bah résiste ou pas non mais est-ce
que vous faites pas en gros bien sûr on
fait des scénarios et on imagine on a
des hypothèses mais est-ce que vous
aussi vous faites pas des scénarios et
des
hypothèes je est-ce queil faut garder
les
barrages les barrages les barrages
hydrauliques oui est-ce qu'il faut les
garder bah ça disons qu' aujourd'hui ils
ont une utilité de produire de l'énergie
débon est-ce qu'il faut les garder parce
que si le barrage de vousglance ouis
mais il y a y a des risques ah bah il y
a des dem des milliers de morts à Lyon
si le barrage de la Grande dience en
Suisse pète ou il y a 20000 morts à son
est-ceon comme en Ukraine un barrage est
attaqué par alors est-ce qu'on garde les
barrages ben si l'armée russe tire sur
la centrale nucléaire de zaporija vous
voyez je veux dire ça marche dans la
question sur les barrages est-ce qu'on
garde les barrages y a des risques
question il y a non il y a des risques
avec les barrages on garde les barrages
tous les jours il y a des gens qui
meurent en voitures est-ce qu'on garde
les voitures ou d'accord c'estd que vous
vous ce que vous dites c'est que vous
dites en fait attribue trop de risque ce
que je dis c'est que tout ce qu'on fait
est un arbitrage risque bénéfice tout
absolument tout et donc je comprends pas
pourquoi en ce qui concerne le nucléaire
on n'accepte pas de rentrer dans ce
raisonnement risque bénéfice donc on
regarde les bénéfices on regarde les
risques il y a le le pour les barrages
on considère que l'arbitrage risque
bénéfice fait qu'on garde barrages alors
que l'installation de production
électrique qui a fait le plus de morts
en Europe de très loin euh c'est le
barrage de vagon longaron quand une
vague de cru a zigouillé de 1500
personnes en Italie au début des années
60 donc enfin voilà donc je je ce que je
dis juste c'est qu' je vois pas pourquoi
le nucléaire ferait exception à cette à
cette analyse risque bénéfice et que si
on veut regarder les risques du
nucléaire d'un peu près c'est quelque
chose qui est très technique et très
compliqué euh parce que reprendre
l'exemple des déchets ducl
est-ce que est-ce que à votre avis
quelle est la part des la proportion des
Français qui sont capables de me citer
deux éléments qu'on trouve dans les
déchets nucléaires bah alors dans les
produit de dans les produits de fission
oui mais est-ce que alors ça veut dire
que on parle de quelque chosees que les
gens ne sont pas capables de définir
donc c'est toujours quand un truc est
très mal défini et très mystérieux on a
toujours plus peurè a beaucoup de gens
qui ont raconté la dangerosité extrême
de ces de ces déchets là
donc et alors pours mais il y a beaucoup
de gens ok ok mais si on regarde le
raisonnement du risque parce que
effffectivement c'est c'est un c'est un
c'est une vraie manière de raisonner
quel est l'avantage quel est le risque
et on fait un arbitrage comme vous dites
depuis tout à l'heure mais si ok alors
il y a vous faites un point sur les
dangers des barrag en cas d'accident
comparé au danger des centrales nucléair
mais si on fait une autre comparaison
qui en fait au fond celle qui se pose à
nous aujourd'hui qui est entre un
réacteur nucléaire et un parc éolien
qu'il soit en mer ou sur terre
et un parc photovoltaïque bah là c'est
différent quand même parce
que un accident de d'éolienne imaginons
un M qui tombe ça doit pouvoir être
imaginé ça doit être possible aurait
bien moins de conséquences dramatiqu que
un accident de réacteur pourquoi est-ce
que ça marcherait pas en faveur
des dans cette comparaison là oui non
pour la biodiversité il vaut beaucoup
mieux le nucléaire euh parce que ça
occupe beaucoup moins de surface et ça
demande beaucoup moins de métau donc ça
demande beaucoup moins de mine me
regardez pas avec C là c'est les
biologistes même qui le disent vous
dites des trucs vous dites des trucs
franchement qui peuvent des fois nous
décoiffer c'estàd vous dites même quand
il a un accident nucléaire en fait c'est
pas si grave
euh si si je reste à la comparaison on
viendra aux accidents après je reste à
la
comparaison je dis deux choses je dis
deux choses en ce qui concerne les la
biodiversité le nucléaire et beaucoup
mieux que le les Z si je réchauffement
des rivières et des fleuves et attent
causé par les central nuire etentatoire
à la biiversité je pas beaucoup on a
fait des comptages de poissons justement
liés au petits surplu de réchauffement
qu'il y a eu et cetera et les comptages
font montrent que les poissons
l'abondance se change pas
euh je vous assure faut faut lire ce
genre de truc et en ce qui d'autres
études en allez-y allez-y allez on vous
écoute on vous écoute je mar en ce qui
concerne la qu'est-ce que je dire et en
ce qui concerne la biodiversité là c'est
pareil ça été documenté les biologistes
vous disent le nucléaire c'est mieux
parce que ça demande en gros il faut 10
fois plus de métal 10 à 50 fois plus de
métal ça dépend du métal pour exploiter
une énergie diffuse comme le vent ou le
soleil que pour une exploiter une
énergie très concentrée comme le
nucléaire donc par kilwh faut 10 à 50
fois plus il faut 1000 fois plus
d'espace 1000 fois plus d'espace pour
faire de l'électricité avec du solaire
qu'avec du nucléaire pour arriver à la
même puissance pour arriver à la même
quantité d'électricité produite dans la
D 1000 fois plus d'espace c'est bien du
reste pour ça que on commence à voir
aujourd'hui des problèmes avec des gens
qui disent j'en veux pas chez moi parce
qu'en fait il faut multiplier les les
installations partout et si on en a
quelques-unes bah vous avez quelques
opposants locaux si vous en avez 1000
fois plus en pas 1000 fois plus mais des
centaines de fois plus bah vous allez
avoir des centaines de fois plus le
débat donc pour la biodiversité
j'insiste le nucléaire c'est mieux euh
et et donc et donc non on peut pas dire
que le que et quand vous
regardez quand vous regardez et quand
vous regardez les risques pour la santé
humaine ouis c'est quand même plus grave
vous quand vous regardez non non quand
vous regardez les risques pour la santé
humaine et que vous allez voir les
articles qui sont plus qui qui est
légitime pour documenter les risques sur
la santé humaine les médecins les
médecins du travail notamment non les
médecins tout court les épidémiologistes
pas les médecins du trail catastrophes
là non non les les épidémiologistes les
G qui font les études de cor et bien ces
gens-là vous disent accident compris
accident compris l'énergie nucléaire est
la plus sûre des énergies à parité avec
léolien voilà c'est ça qu'il vous disent
et de toute façon je reviens à ma
question des accidents nucléaires vous
dites ça c'est dans un article de gens
qui ont vu votre BD et qui du coup dans
alternative économique je crois sur
reporter écrivent Jean covissi une
imposture écologique alors les mots sont
quand même assez dur bon mais il
cite je parle pas de l' en général ni du
titre je parle de ce qu'il dit une
citation de vous Fukushima en fait ça a
été surtout un problème médiatique
majeur mais pas un désastre sanitaire ou
environnemental majeur du point de vue
des écosystèmes et c'est pas du tout de
l'ironie un accident de centrale est une
excellente nouvelle car ça crée
instantanément une réserve naturelle
parfaite c'est de l'ironie non c'est une
réalité si vous demandez au biologistes
il y a eu un congrès de de biologistes
sur les conséquences de la zone
interdite de Tchernobyl et ils vous
disent ça a été une bénédiction pour la
biodiversité oui un accident nucléaire
est problématique dans les cons c'est
problématique mais évidemment que c'est
problématique mais je dis juste c'est un
paradoxe de voir que ternobyl a créé une
réserve instantanément une réserve
naturelle où sont revenus les loutres
les castors les les chevaux de Préval on
a même réinttroduit des chevaux de
pralski mais la question du risque alors
la question du risque pour les individus
euh elle est que le alors tchernoby
c'était très particulier parce que c'est
un accident qui n'est techniquement pas
possible avec l'essentiel des réacteurs
qu' a dans le oui c'est un autre modèle
de réacteur modè c'est un modèle qui
comporte du graphite le graphite c'est
du carbone c'est comme les mines de
crayon vous savez dans le cœur et ça
brûle et en fait ce qui a fait la
gravité de l'accident à Tchernobyl c'est
que les Russes avaient un un concept de
réacteur pas autorisé en France dans
lequel euh donc le cœur comportait du
graphite et c'est l'incendie de ce de ce
graphite qui a qui a propulsé un panage
d'autres accidents nucléaires dans
d'autres pays qui ont été sans
conséquence pour la santé humaine bah
Fukushima il y a quand même Fukushima il
y a pas il y a l'évacuation non mais
l'évacuation a des conséquences sur le
les rayonnements ionisants non bah alors
vous vous savez très bien que cette
affirmation est contredite par de
nombreuses personnes non mais juste mais
de nombreuses personnes ça dép pour
signaler et que et que par ailleurs bon
là on parlait des accid pas refaire le
débat que j'ai fait sur franceculture
mais la question de savoir qui est
légitime pour contredire quoi c'est ça
le sujet ah mais c'est tout à fait un
sujet euh que nous n'avons pas
nécessairement le temps de d'aborder
maintenant car non mais moi j'avais en
on a tout à fait le temps de l'aborder
maintenant parce que c'est le fond de
l'affaire
oui c'est qui est légitime pour parler
de quoi qui est légitime pour parler de
quoi ok euh euh moi j'avais quand même
envie de de signaler la question de la
santé des travailleurs du nucléaire
puisque là on parle de l'exposition aux
doses en situation d'accident qui sont
même s'ils sont dramatiques quand même
très rares dans l'histoire du 20e siècle
en revanche la situation des
travailleurs du nucléaire et de leur
exposition à un environnement de travail
euh radioactif lui il est routinier il
est même quotidien pour tout un paquet
de personnes et il expose ces personnes
à des risques sanitaires et de ce point
de vue-là c'est pas Mediapart
quiil y a aucun problème on est là pour
discuter mais c'est pas mediaapart qui
dit que c'est une étude qui est sortie
l'été dernier dans le British Medical
Journal et qui est fort intéressant
parce que c'est un étude justement sur
une grande cohorte de travailleurs donc
quand même 310000 travailleurs de
l'industrie du nucléaire en France au
Royaume-Uni et aux États-Unis et qui
réhausent euh leur évaluation du risque
euh de mourir d'un cancer quand on est
un travailleur du nucléaire euh donc la
question est sachant cela sachant cela
euh euh est-ce que c'est un risque
acceptable est-ce que la société euh
française par exemple euh doit euh se
résoudre à ça et accepter parmi ell
certains travailleurs prennent un risque
que d'autres ne prennent pas au nom du
fait de produire de l'électricité
décarboné alors j'ai pas vu cette étude
donc je peux pas la
commenter voilà tout ce que je peux vous
dire c'est
que je verrais hors cette étude que je
n'ai pas
lu ce que je sais c'est que les salariés
d'df étant extrêmement bien suivis sur
le plan médical oui ils sont globalement
en meilleure santé que la moyenne de la
population française mais pas les
sous-traitants c'est tout le problème de
ce qui s'est passé à EDF et qui est
montré par la sociologie du travail
c'est que oui parce que vous vous savez
très bien vous répondez sur les
personnes qui sont pas les plus exposés
je vous dis ce que je sais ouais c'est
les sous-traitants et les et les c'est
les soustraitants et les critèes
prennent le plus de doses au sein des
centrale nucléaire je ne sais pas pour
ça il faudrait que travologi non c'est
pas un travail sociologique ça c'est TR
il y a des travaux sociologiques sur ce
sujet c'est pas un travail sociologique
qui permet de savoir si les gens
prennent des doses c'est un travail
dosimétrique c'est sociologique de
savoir non non non non non non non non
c'est un travail une dose ça se mesure
avec un dosimètre tout à fait donc ça
veut dire que il faut que on mesure les
doses reçues par les gens sous-traitants
et il faut qu'il y ait un tiers
indépendant qui aille voir les doses
reçues par les sous-traitants et qui
vous disoup documentation mais la
sociologie c'est qui prend la dose c'est
pas sur la dose c'est qui la prend entre
les travailleurs prendre une dose moi je
le fais à chaque fois que je vais
prendre je vais suivre un examen médical
donc la question oui vous travaillez pas
tous les jours dans un dans une centrale
ça ve dire qu'on est obligé de par les
chiffres donc c'est bien ce que je
disais donc moi je ne vais pas commenter
cette étude parce pas vu donc je sais
pas ce qu' a dedans je vous dis juste
que en ce qui concerne les chiffres on
peut pas affirmer les sous-traitants
prennent plus que les travailleurs d'EDF
si on n pas accès au dosimètres des
sous-traitants voilà c'est juste ça que
je suis en train de vous dire exactement
comme on peut pas dire ils ont plus
souvent la fièvre si on n pas accès à
leur thermomètrre il faut il faut avoir
accès personnellement moi j'ai pas accès
au dosimèes des sous-raitants et donc
j'ai pas plus de commentaires à faire
là-dessus la seule chose la seule chose
que je peux dire c'est que et de très
loin le salarié le plus iradiier de
France n'est pas un travailleur de
nucléaire c'est Thomas Pesquet parce que
à chaque fois que il va lui pour le coup
il est très bien suivi médicalement oui
mais à chaque fois qu'il va la Station
spatiale internationale il se prend 200
mil vertes en 6 mois c'est-à-dire 20
fois c'est 10 fois pardon la dose
maximale annuelle pour un travailleur du
nucléaire probablement plus suivi que
travailleurs du nucléaire médical et il
est suivi et il y a une autre Corte qui
prend également des rayonnements de
façon chronique tout tout le temps c'est
le personnel voilà le personnel navigant
il nous reste on va dire une dizaine une
quinzaine de minutes on va parler de
l'aspect de de de de gestion de ce
système nucléaire on a eu récemment une
loi de relance nucléaire dont on peut
pas dire vraiment qu'elle a été mise en
débat dans la dans la société euh il y a
eu l'accélération du nucléaire a même
été votée finalement avant la fin du
débat public sur le programme de du
nouveau nucléaire il y a une conduite de
la politique nucléaire en France qui on
peut dire et probablement partagé entre
petit nombre de gens l'Élysée
régulièrement réunit régulièrement un
Conseil de politique nucléaire qui se
réunit dans une certaine opacité faut
bien le dire est-ce que c'est une bonne
façon de conduire une une de cette
politique là cette opacité ou est-ce que
vous dites elle est
nécessaire vu la hauteur des enjeux ou
est-ce qu'on pourrait faire différemment
est-ce que là elle est universelle enfin
je veux dire toute réunion de travail à
l'intérieur d'une entreprise est opaque
il y a pas il y a pas un journaliste
présent dans toute réunion travail dans
une entreprise oui mais un pays c'est
pas une entreprise je je ok il y a pas
il y a pas un journaliste présent dans
toute réunion ministérielle dans toute
réunion enfin je veux dire donc bon
est-ce que c'est opaque parce que à
chaque fois tout se fait pas derrière
dans un aquarium avec les gens qui
écoutent tout je ne suis pas je suis je
ne suis pas sûr queon puisse gérer
facilement un pays ou une entreprise ou
whatever avec tout le monde peut
partager ses choix auprès de la
population on peut oui alors c'est
normalement fait euh avec un certain
avec avec des élections un parlement et
cetera en ce qui concerne la loi
d'accélération sur le nucléaire il y a
eu au même moment une loi d'accélération
sur les renouvelables dans lequel il a
comme pour le nucléaire on a dit il y a
un certain nombre de procédures qui
s'appliquent normalement aux
installations qui enfin qui un certain
nombre de procédures pr de débat
préalabl et cetera là on dit allez hop
on va on va faire ça parce que il faut
qu'on accélère donc c'est pas propre
nucléaire cette histoire là et en fait
de tout temps donc je dis pas que c'est
nécessairement une bonne chose je dis
c'est pas propre nucléaire tous les gens
qu'on a exproprié pour construire des
autoroutes c'était pas propre nucléaire
donc voilà donc le le la question pour
moi elle est plus dans est-ce que sur le
fond l'objet lui-même est intéressant ou
pas c'est ça le premier niveau du débat
et après il y a un deuxième niveau du
débat qui est si l'objet est intéress si
l'objet est pas intéressant bah en fait
il y a pas lieu de l'accélérer et si
l'objet est intéressant il faut voir
comment est-ce que les modalités
d'accélération comment est-ce enfin
est-ce qu'on les considère légitime ou
pas voilà c'est ça le c'est ça le le
sujet mais quand on voit que la loi
enfin pardon mais la loi d'accélération
du nucléaire est voté pendant qu' a
encore lieu le débat public sur la
création de nouveau réacteur nucléair au
point que la Commission nationale du
débat public pendant qu' le débat de la
CNDP oui mais non parce que le débat
public il faut qu'on se mette
d'accord Commission nationale du débat
public au point que cette commission a
dû arrêter ces trabau
alors à
serors vous décider avant qu'on ait
rendu notre avis est-ce que là il y a
pas un yatus démocratique en terme de
calendrier je dois dire que c'était pas
très fin d'avoir fait ça évident je ve
dire ou bien vous dites on est dans
l'urgence et donc je fais même pas de
débat à la CNDP ou bien vous parce que
si un jour on doit déclarer la guerre je
suis pas sûr que on fera un débat à la
cndpé pas oui non mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que quand il y a une vraie
urgence ou ou ou un sentiment d'urgence
partagé par tout le monde à ce moment et
un certain nombre de procédures on pass
outre si on considère qu'on a le temps
de faire les procédures on attend
qu'elles aillent jusqu'à leur terme ça
ça me paraît évident et quand on décide
de fusionner les deux instances de
sûreté nucléaire sans même demander aux
personnes directement concerné si c'est
une bonne idée les consulter sur à quoi
ça pourrait servir et là je parle de la
fusion de l'ASN autor du nucléaire et de
l'IRSN est-ce que ça c'est une bonne
manière démocratique et mature de
fonctionner j'ai malheureusement pas
grand chose ch à dire sur ce dossier là
parce que je l'ai pas regardé en détail
donc je
je tu voulais poser une question je
crois en plus
surtique aussi encore sur l'aspect sur
l'aspect démocratique parce que voilà
c'est ça fait des décennies en fait que
les critiques du nucléaire disent on n
jamais de moment de consultation et au
final la société française ne s'est
jamais prononcé sur être favorable ou
défavorable au nucléaire finalement
c'est c'est une question qui se pose à
une société est-ce que est-ce que vous
vous considérez vous dites voilà encore
une fois pour vous c'est une petite
partie mais une partie aujourd'hui
importante stratégique de des moment de
transition énergétique est-ce que vous
vous seriez favorable estce qu'il est
aujourd'hui une consultation sur faut-il
ou non garder le nucléaire compte tenu
de tous ces enjeux sanitaires mais aussi
économique lié à cette décision là alors
ce genre de consultation ça existe en ce
moment tous les de mois s'appelle
sondage bah non est-ce que c'est la même
chose un sondage et une consultation
démocratique je
je j'ai beaucoup de mal à savoir ce
qu'est une consultation démocratique dit
autrement c'est quoi une un référendum
par exempleférendum par exemple alors
les référendums dans notre pays je
considère et ça c'est pas propre
nucléire que c'est des c'est des c'est
des exercices casse-gueule parce que les
les rouspetteurs que nous sommes on a
tendance à répondre autant à la personne
qui pose la question qu'à la question
elle-même c'est très difficile dans
notre pays on serait chez les Suisses je
vous dirais pas ça parce qu'il sont
routinés oui parce que c'est c'est c'est
ça ça participe de la culture du pays et
cetera euh et puis du reste chez les
Suisses il y a eu des référendums sur le
nucléaire et qui a 10ans d'intervalle
ont donnit des résultats opposés chez
les Suédois c'est exactement pareil donc
euh voilà donc est-ce que un référendum
sur le nucléaire c'est la fin de
l'histoire pour toujours avec un grand
moment démocratique et cetera je suis
pas sûr euh parce que les circonstances
changent et cetera est-ce qu'il y a un
mode parfait de consultation de la
population sur un sujet précis je suis
pas sûr malheureusement quel que soit
quel que soit le sujet euh euh le le le
le débat il vit avec avec la presse avec
les les les même si c'est un exercice
imparfait et très imparfait du reste
avec les sondages avec les essais avec
enfin voilà je suis pas sûr encore une
fois queil y ait un un un un truc très
particulier qui faille idéaliser il y a
il y a 20 ans j'avais écrit dans un
bouquin que sur le changement climatique
il faudrait faire un référendum pour
demander aux gens est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord pour que on continue notre mode
de vie et puis devienne que pour a ou
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord bon et bon
mais en fait c'était une idée naïve
euh que j'assume tout à fait d'avoir une
idée naïve he maintenant j'en suis un
peu revenu au sens où je pense qu'il y a
pas encore une fois euh un truc parfait
qui règle définitivement la question et
puis à côté que des trucs euh qui qui
vont pas je pense que malheureusement la
vie est plus compliquée que ça euh et
que il y a un certain nombre de trucs
pas parfaits avec lesquels il faut
composer pour comprendre dernière
question pour comprendre un peu ben
justement d'où vous parlez quelle est de
votre vision du monde au-delà de
l'aspect expert des des choses puisqu'on
parle beaucoup ici aussi d'avenir et de
modèle en général puis nous avvez dit
que le nucléaire c'était une petite
partie et que derrière il y avait des
changements de société importants donc
pour creuser un peu juste en dernière
question dire autrement c'est la partie
c'est paradoxalement la partie facile
voilà pour pour atteindre justement la
question d'une d'un d'un d'une
révolution par que vous parlez de
révolution dans par rapport à à à à
l'énergie euh est-ce que c'est juste
finalement en changeant le mix en
modifiant un peu quelques habitudes
d'autres disent euh ça le changement le
véritable changement pour justement
essayer de tenir les clous des objectifs
qu'on s'est fixé peut-être 1 dem 2 % 2
degrés mais peut-être pas beaucoup plus
que ça sinon ça va être très
difficilement vivable ce serait de
d'interroger les les fondements de notre
modèle économique euh et
de d'interroger le le le capitalisme et
le néolibéralisme tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
vous dites finalement pourquoi pas mais
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas la
priorité là alors c'est un si c'est un
débat intéressant alors je je vais je
vais le complexifier un peu
euh la la société occidentale est
aujourd'hui très largement capitaliste
et libérale mais on a connu des
expériences de système un peu différents
ou très différents en Chine où on a eu
plutôt au début une espèce de
capitalisme d'État
qui n'a pas montré que c'était
particulièrement plus doux pour
l'environnement
euh on a eu également en Union
soviétique quelque chose qui ressemblait
à un capitalisme d'État et qui n'a pas
non plus été spécialement plus doux pour
l'environnement donc je pense que
malheureusement le mal est plus profond
si je puis dire que le système politique
ou la construction politique du moment
c'est quoi c'est que l'humanité ne ne
changera pas de modèle de
surconsommation c'est c'est que on a des
c'est qu'on a des pulsions animales
entre guillemets euh qui nous poussent
euh à faire des choses qu'on devrait pas
faire euh par exemple connaissez la
fable de la cigale et de la fourmi euh
bon bah le la la vertu dans cette
affaire est du côté de l'accumulation
parce que on sait jamais c'est la
précaution et cetera euh il y a deux
siècles quand vous aviez réussi vous
étiez dedus euh parce que c'était
l'héritage d'une époque où pour passer
l'hiver bah c'était mieux d'avoir
constitué un peu de graveant l'hiver
parce que si jamais vous aviez pas à
manger pendant 2 jours ça vous
facilitait la vie donc en fait on a on
on hérite et et notre code génétique a
pas changé en de siècles hein euh et
même pas en 1000 an donc on hérite d'un
d'un de réflexe et de de une
constitution biologique j'ai envie de
dire qui nous pousse gentiment alors
c'est heureusement pas la seule
caractéristique que nous avons on est
aussi des animaux sociaux on connaît la
coopération on connait l'entraide on
connaitt et cetera heureusement mais euh
on on a quand même une une poussion une
pulsion au au toujours plus c'est ça qui
fait que très étonnamment quand vous
gagnez le SMIC vous avez envie de gagner
deux fois le SMIC mais quand vous gagnez
un million vous avez aussi envie de
gagner 2 millions en
fait donc le système capitaliste
l'option la plus probable c'est ça que
vous dites et alors ce qu'on il y a des
je pense qu'il y a des choses qu'on ne
changera pas je pense qu'on ne changera
pas l'envie d'avoir quelque chose à soi
qui soit privé alors entre la totalité
de l'appareil productif et juste un bout
d'appartement il y a toute une il y a
tout un tas de nuances de gris la
question est là où on met le curseur je
suis ravi moi pour ma part que la
production électrique dans ce pays soit
soit géré par l'État je trouve ça très
bien euh je trouve ça très bien je
trouve que ça a très bien marché jusqu'à
maintenant que le système ferroviaire
soit géré par une entreprise publique je
trouve ça marche plutôt bien voilà
est-ce que voilà est-ce que j'ai
fondamentalement envie que mon
épicier soit pas propriétaire de son
épicerie ou que par pas forcément de
mode d'organisation de la société je
vous parle de décroître collectivement
et j'entends mais parce que mon épicier
est aussi un capitaliste d'accord il il
est propriétaire de son outi de
production il y a une société
commerciale et cetera donc en fait pour
moi le vrai débat c'est un débat de
curseur c'est-à-dire estce est-ce qu'
aujourd'hui on est allé trop loin dans
le libéralisme à l'évidence oui est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui le capitalisme est bien
régulé à l'évidence non est-ce donc il y
a tout un tas de trucs qu'il faut
changer est-ce que il faut totalement
supprimer l'idée même qu'il y a un bout
de capitalisme dans un coin je suis pas
sûr ouis on en est loin de toute façon
non mais voilà c'est ça c'est c'est pour
moi il me semble encore plus le seul
débat qui par ailleurs a une portée un
peu pratique c'est celui-là parce que si
on est dans une espèce de rêve
romantique qui n'a pas de chance de se
réaliser en fait on perd un peu son
essayer de le faire avancer moi pas
romantique merci
Jean-Marc dans certaines circonstances
merci jean-marcov d'êt venu sur le
plateau de mediap merci à toi jade pour
ce débat intéressant fouillé et posé à
très vite sur
[Musique]
mediap